bonjour estelle alors emmanuel macron a
déjà distillé quelques indices sur ce
qui attend les français à partir du 3
mai oui depuis le 26 avril marqué par la
rentrée scolaire emmanuel macron
esquisse les différentes étapes qui
devraient mener vers une réouverture
progressive du pays
avec cette première étape que l'on
connaît tous déjà le 3 mai date à
laquelle les restrictions de circulation
seront levés jean castex
elle a d'ailleurs confirmé hier s'en
suivra plusieurs étapes jusqu'à la fin
gens comme l'a expliqué à de son côté
emmanuel macron on sait aussi que est la
réouverture des restaurants pourraient
dépendre du taux d'incidence est des
départements le chef de l'état qui a
insisté la levée des restrictions se
fera tout doucement pas de précipitation
donc du côté de l'exécutif cette sortie
sera progressive à mesure que la
campagne de vaccination se déploie à
souligner une fois de plus le premier
ministre hier une sortie progressive qui
sera donc détaillé deux mains par
emmanuel macron une prise de parole sous
forme d'entretiens qui sera publié dans
la presse quotidienne régionale
alors est elle a été ce qui pourrait
expliquer cette prudence
et bien tout d'abord olivier est la
situation épidémique elle s'améliore
certes mais le niveau du circulation de
circulation du virus reste élevée la
décrue est plus lente qu'au mois de
novembre dernier jean castex
elle a expliqué à l'impact sur les
hospitalisations ne ça ne se traduit
encore que très timidement dans
l'évolution du nombre de malades en
réanimation fin de citation et puis il
ya l'évolution de la vaccination qu'il
faut prendre en compte une campagne qui
avance à très bon rythme selon le
premier ministre
rappelons l'objectif 20 millions de
primo vacciner à la mi-mai cet objectif
il est à notre portée a souligné
matignon et puis avec cette réouverture
progressive
l'exécutif souhaite éviter les stop and
go et permettre à l'hôpital d'être
soulagé